Hey guys welcome back to the workshop! Today,
We're going to try to make our own version of a simple experiment you may have seen before
This little device here lets you connect to soda bottles together two make a tornado tube. To make it work,
You simply fill one soda bottle two-thirds full of water,
Attach the tornado tube device and then screw the other soda bottle into the top of it
You can see that there are threads that hold the device onto the soda bottle
And then a small smooth hole down through the center so to make this device work the way we want to we're going to flip
It upside down and quickly shake it in a circular motion. Watch what happens!
Now, as you can see, we've got this cool water vortex forming in the upper chamber
So what happens is as the water swirls around it's able to drain just on the edges of the hole in the connector while the
Center of the hole has air flowing up through it into the bottle on the top.
Because air is able to flow into the top bottle as the water drains into the lower bottle, the pressure
Between them stays equal, and the water is able to flow smoothly. Now we see how this version works,
let's try to build our own! All of the equipment that we're gonna need today is two clear 2 liter soda bottles, a 1 inch
PVC coupling, and a glue gun
Now our 1 inch PVC coupling fits over our cap with just a little bit of room to spare. To secure it
I'm gonna take some hot glue and
spread that all the way around the sides of this cap which has some ridges on it to help with grip and I'm hoping that'll
Also help it stick to our PVC a little bit better. To ensure we have a good grip on the PVC itself,
I'm just gonna take a little bit of sandpaper and rough up the inside
I'm trying to apply the glue fairly quickly so that it doesn't cool down,
before I can then fit our coupling over the cap and you can see that the coupling has a
Middle stripe going around the middle and we want that to end sort of right at the same level as the soda bottle cap
With our coupling attached to the first cap, now
We'll take the glue gun go around the edge to ensure good connection and then keep adding glue covering the entire cap. That way
We'll have just a small pool of hot glue a couple of millimeters thick
As soon as we have our hot glue pool down inside our coupling
We'll take our other soda bottle with the cap attached flip it upside down and press the cap down into the hot glue
There's a pretty good amount of hot glue in the coupling there
So we're gonna give that just a couple minutes to cool down once it has will try and disconnect both bottles from their caps
inside the connector
There we go!
First bottle comes off pretty nicely
You can actually see that when I press the bottle down into the puddle of hot glue some of it oozed up
past the cap that's what we want. It means
There's glue surrounding the sides of the cap and should give it a really nice connection
So now we have our two caps inside our PVC coupling pressed against each other being held together with a bunch of hot glue
Now what we need to do is drill a hole to let the water drain from one bottle into the other. To drill the hole,
I'm using a 3/8 inch drill bit
Alright we now have our tornado tube connector device
That should be working, so let's attach it to both bottles and see if we can get that nice vortex. We were looking at
Stand it up straight
There we go! We have our tornado in a bottle... or I guess it's in water not air so that's a maelstrom, not a tornado
There you go how to build a working tornado tube connector in just a few minutes with some very basic parts
There are a couple things
I want to try to make this look just a little bit cooler though as
The water is spinning down from one bottle into the other you can see the vortex in the center now looks really cool
But I want to try something that lets you really see the water swirling around itself
So I'm going to add just a little bit of glitter to our water and see what that does
Alright, I'm gonna try and pour some glitter into our bottle without it getting everywhere because I don't really want a glitter covered workshop
It's all over my gloves already! It's spreading. The workshop is going to be glittery forever!
Let's start by just shaking this up a little bit to get the glitter to mix into the water
There we go
Weirdly still it's floating quite a bit on the top. All right, I'm gonna try flipping it and swirling it around
There you go, there's your tornado!
And you can definitely see it swirling around a lot more. Glitter does do a good job of catching the light
I guess that's kind of the whole point of glitter. This is interesting, if you look down at the bottom
How much of the glitter doesn't want to mix into the water and just sort of stays on the surface?
All right, let's try that again!
As soon as the vortex forms for a second all of the surface glitter gets pulled down into it you have this really glittery
Vortex and then it clears out, and then you just have water with glitter in it swirling around and it
settles in a layer there
Wide vortex and just pulls the surface glitter down. It's like stuck to the sides of it and, Ha! It's really cool!
It's funny it's not it's not dropping. It's like on the
the water side of
The vortex not the bubble side of the vortex so some of it's just stuck there. That's an interesting effect
All right that works pretty cool
Let's move on to our next filler
Our we've emptied out most of the glitter and now we're going to try filling one of our bottles about 2/3 full of tonic water
Tonic water is a sweetened beverage that contains quinine
And we'll see the advantage of something with quinine in just a second. All right, We've got our tonic water
There's our connector. T
That's already ending up in our tonic water, but that's all right
There we go the bubbles are doing a fairly nice job similar to the glitter that lets you see it spinning around,
But that's not the real advantage of using tonic water now the reason we're trying using tonic water is that quinine
Glows in a blacklight, so I have here a little blacklight check this out
Just lights it up bright blue
kinda cool, you can see the path that the light is taking through the bottle. Alright, and I also happen to have a
Larger blacklight here. Wow you can already see how much that's lighting it up
So let's get this tornado going and I'll put the large black light up against it
And we'll have this just glowing blue tornado! here goes
Ha! Look at that
Beautiful glowing Maelstrom
Looks like we found some liquid from the movie avatar and put it in the bottle
There we go we filled it with quinine and put a black light next to it and got a really cool
Blue glowing effect now fill the bottle back up with regular water, and I'm going to be adding some glow-in-the-dark
Craft paint this is an acrylic based paint which should dilute nicely into the water when I shake it up
So I'm going to pour this in and I'm gonna see if we can get this to glow in the dark
That looks like a good amount
That looks pretty well mixed, let's give just a little bit more to make sure
I'm gonna try and squeeze the foam out and pour that off into the sink. I don't want bubbles
Now it's great
All right, just a quick test
I'm gonna be using a blacklight to see the result blacklight is really good at charging glow-in-the-dark stuff very quickly
Oh, Beautiful look at that
Let's get some swirling action and then just
Ha! That looks really cool
Just lights up and makes
Individual tiny tiny little paint particles glow and those get caught up in the swirl of the water
And they're so small they don't hold much of a glowing charge for long, but it's still pretty cool. All right
Let's try getting a whole whirl pool here. Now of course the paint has made the liquid a bit more opaque
So you can't really see the whirlpool itself, but now when we light up part of it with our blacklight
It starts swirling around really cool
When I hold it right here
You can watch the glowing paint run down the side of the bottle and mix with the rest of the paint
Let's try with the big black light see what happens
Get some charge see if we get all of it glowing before we start our tornado
This black light is about hmm a million times more powerful. All right! Let's flip this
That looks pretty cool
This glowing up here runs down. It's not glowing too much on the sidewalls
I bet I can make it glow more on the sides
That looks so cool as it drips down into the bottle. It's just
like liquid light pouring down
There you go how to build your very own vortex funnel device for just a couple of dollars
And it only takes a few minutes
I hope you've also liked the look of the glitter, the tonic water, and the glow-in-the-dark paint
to give your swirling vortex a couple of different looks
Thanks guys for joining us for this project today, and we'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then!
Extra-fine meaning it gets everywhere even more and is even harder to get rid of
Aww, I was doing so well! ): ... A couple drops spilled nothing too bad
Hey guys, thanks so much for caring about our content and our channel so much
It really is amazing to have great people like you
Jumping in to watch every new video that gets uploaded and watching it to the end, you really are
Amazing and we appreciate you for that! <3
Captioned by Emma Forsyth, Admirer of Nate's abs! <3